who's stacking the cups don't stack the
cups can we just keep water in here and
then just drink our side beer rinse your
ball rinse your balls we have a water
cup in Purell
oh that wouldn't count in any way
because you didn't wash your ball before
wash your ball kind of take us down
through biological warfare is how you're
doing trying to get a sick over here
because you need to wash your damn balls
and I got this all right
fade away game set match blouses if I
make them all you know I mean the games
too quick here we go oh my god nothing
Oh
Oh
oh that's one Coby Mamba King James ah
ah pardon ah dip it dip it Westbrook's
boom baby
right this is not regulation size if I
get one ball in one cup on island you
drink that cup plus one of my choice
hey yo let me get a straight line let me
get a play button let me get a Jesus
cross and let me get the Hawaiian island
is where you put six cups you don't make
it touch each other
elbow elbow you can now put your elbow
over the edge of the table you can pull
the cup I got the same one is heat it
that's that tub that's game over no
rebuttal job man you know what my
shoulder dude ah zip fluorescent lights
your or is it like my contacts I only
can do beer pong with lagers this is how
it is girls like [ __ ] it is stuffy in
here yep we put the AC on oh god the AC
blew my ball my girlfriend just broke up
with me I never played a game I've never
played this game before
what yes I'm a natural what can I say
skies I never play beer pong
what is that
okay all right really weak bells it's
not a secret if you bounce it every time
every bounce sounds who do your home get
in my house yeah I'm a brick wall
distraction yo let me get a celeb shot
buckets ah my bad guys yo let me get a
slice huh yo let me get a sledge shot
yes same same tall man yo can I get a
slap shot all right yo after you guys
are done we got next
yo we got next so we got next left when
she got next after she got next we got
next
is there even a list and we got next I
mean